サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッタパリヨダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日はこのテーマについて話します
えーとですね スライドを作りましたけど
昨日夜 今日は面白くないんですね
だからまあ自分では面白くないんだったらね
話にならんだから そういうわけで
ここまで電車で来るとき
ちょっとメモを書いておいたんです
それ話して 時間が余ったらスライドに行きます
あの後ろの楽屋の部屋で使っているときは
あの あの バイオリンのバイオリンのあれ
何といいますか あのリハーサルやってる音を聞こえたんですね
ちらっと本人も見えたんですけど
かなり美しい女性の方でね
そこで私が考えたのは
もし私があのバイオリンを弾いたらどうなるのかと
みんなに殺されるでしょうね
なんだこれと ギャーギャーギャーと音を出してもね
演奏にならないんですね
そこでもし私が弁解したら
え？これワイリンが悪いんだと
正しい弁解ですかね 私は殺さないでくれと
悪いのはワイリンだと
だって音を出したのはワイリンだからね
嫌な音を出したのは でもその弁解はおかしいね
悪いのは誰ですかね 正しくそれ演奏しなかった
できなかった 訓練を受けなかった私にあるでしょ
というわけで 私たちはいろんなものに文句を言い出しちゃったりして
自分の心をものすごく硬くしているんですよ
だから悪いのはあなたですよと
悪いのは政府ですよ 悪いのは奥さんですよと
あるいは旦那さんが悪いんだよと
言うは言うは言うは のバイオリンの例と同じなんです
結局悪いのはあなたですよ
だからバイオリンの例をよく覚えておいてください
自分の人生に対して それで命って何ですか？生きるって何ですか？というと
これは一切心の働きなんですね
生きているのは心なんですよ
体じゃないんです あの酸素を生きていた
鉄は生きていたって話が聞いた
炭素が生きているんだとか関係ないでしょうに
体の中の炭素 それから水素
窒素 窒素 フォスファラスとか
日本語の名前あまりわかってないんだけどね
もうカーボン オキシジェン
ナイトジェン もうハイドロゲンという
もういろいろ またソーディウム
ポタシウム そんなもんですよ
もうただの そんな生きてる？鉄の塊見て
あ これ生きてるんだって言える？生きてないんです
いくら遺伝子でと あの普通の元素でできてるでしょうに
元素で 遺伝子の中でも命がないんです
だから生きるっていうことは
単に心という働きなんです
だから私のまぶたやらベロやらね
舌やら脳細胞やら手足すべて 40兆の細胞を動かしているのは誰ですかというと心なんです
それで人生はうまくいかない
だったら誰のせい？心のせいなんです
何かやったら失敗する
誰のせい？心のせいです
いろいろ計画立てて頑張ったんだけど
全部パーでいい結果が出なかったと
誰のせい？心のせいなんです
その場合はね くだらん計画を立てた心でしょ
実行できない計画を立てたのはアホな心でしょ
そこで実行できる計画を立てても
途中でおかしいことをしたり
変なことをしたり 判断をミスったりしたのは心でしょ
だから一切責任は心が持つべきなんです
なんで世界でずっと争い
戦い 人殺しがあるんですかね
心が責任を持つべきなんです
今  IS というテログループがいて
ものすごいもう力強く
そこで国民差別 宗教差別
民主差別 あれやこれやとかね
こんな下らんことをやっているのは誰で？心なんですね
ただの腐りかけて腐りかかっている
腐っている 老いている
この肉体を見て それを見ないで俺は偉いんだと思って
ハチャメチャ人生がスムーズに流れないようにしているのは誰ですか？心なんです
だから一切を管理支配しているのは心なんです
で もうわかるでしょ？この心っていうのはアホで腐ったたりなんですね
ろくなことできない 例えば学校に行って
すごい天才的な能力があって
研究して もう超一流の科学者になったところで
もう大量破壊兵器を作るんです
なんだこれはと 超オリンピックではなくて
何でしたっけ？ノーベルメダル取るぐらいの能力の科学者たちが何をやっているかというと
人殺しのためにいろんなカラクリをやっているんですよ
だから何なのかと これはと
普通の金がなくて 強盗に入って見つかったところで人を殺したりする人はけしからんと非難する社会が
あれは非難しませんね
それも心なんです そういうわけで育てるべきなのは心です
戒めるべきなのは心です
浄化するべきなのは心です
幸福になりたければ 人生をうまく生きたければ
心に気をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
一切は心次第です だから
宇宙を支配している神様というのは
仏教から言えば心なんです
そこでもうわかるでしょ？この心が最低の失敗しているんです
で 心が物事を判断するんですよ
だからワーストデシジョン
最低の判断をしているんです
判断して この輪廻という苦しみの回転する悪循環の命の流れを作ったんですね
だから心っていうのは
もう素粒子よりもすっごい速い波長で変化するんだから
もうまあ17倍速いと私は勝手に言ってるんですけど
光の速度よりはね まあそれ別に計算してないんです
あの 仏教ではね まぶたを閉じるときでも
閉じて開ける瞬間でも
何億も心が生まれてなくなるんだと言っているんだからね
テキストでは相当早いんですね
だから早いだからこそ
もう延々延々延々と続くんですね
でもこれがいつでも間違った判断をしているんです
それは仏教用語で無明というんですね
そういうことで  我々の心が物事を見たり聞いたり
判断したりする しかし
いつでも逆さまで wrong side 間違った側面しか見ないんです
例えば我々は鏡を見ると鏡の表を見るでしょ
裏側は見ないでしょ もし誰かが鏡の裏の方を見て
なんだこれって役に立たんやとポイと捨てちゃうと
すごい高価な鏡かもしれませんよ
それは鏡が悪いんじゃなくて
それを捨てて壊した私が間違った wrong side を見たんですね
そこでどうですかね 常に私たちの心が wrong side を見ている
ならば すごくすごくひどくない？超まずくない
捨ててますよね 我々は
人参買ってきても もう皮を捨てて切って食べるんですね
それは我々にとっては正しいんですよ
誰かが人参のあの頭のところとっぽのところとか
剥いた皮だけ食べると
ちょっと wrong side なんですね
一番面白い例があるんです
カニを買ってくる 来るカニを買って
これあまり食べたことないんだけど
よくわかりませんだけど
茹でたりいろんなことして
カニの中身を捨てて甲羅を食べると
wrong side でしょ
そういうことは心が無知なる過去からやってます
すごく wrong side を見ているんです
だから宗教家にもそれを直すことはできなかったんです
お釈迦様以外は ブッダお釈迦様が
もうこっちじゃなくて
こっちで 180度変えて思ってみてくださいと
いわゆる right side 正しい方面を見てくださいと
包丁を取る時は正しい取り方だったらすごい幸せでしょ
間違って包丁を取っちゃうと怪我するでしょ
電気やら火やら水やら何でもかんでもね
正しい使い方があって
正しい使い方をすると幸福になる
間違った使い方をすると
ものすごい災害に遭わなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ道具の場合は我々はあまり失敗していないんだけど
生きるということの場合は完璧
すべての生命が失敗しているんです
成功した人はいません
はい そういうことで 今日は心のストレッチなんですけど
で だからもうちょっと深くこの問題を見なくちゃいけないんですよ
wrong side を見て活動すると
心には何の安らぎもないでしょ
お腹が空いていた人に
私は 1,000円をあげる
その人はその 1,000円を持って花を噛んだら
鉄砲の代わりに その人は不幸になるでしょう
お腹が空いたまんまでしょう
だから我々の心にはストレスがあるんだとかね
あれやこれや言ったって
当たり前なんです 悩み苦しみがある
当たり前 不思議でも何でもないんです
誰かがね 例えば精神的に問題を持っている人は
カウンセラーのところに行って
大変あれやこれや言ったっても
どちらでも問題持っていますよ
カウンセラーもカウンセリングを受ける人も
ですから うーん まずこの
この心 180度 right side 正しい方面見る訓練する前に
今我々の悩み苦しみ 硬いところね
ちょっと具体的に緩和する実践だけまず紹介します
どうやって心が柔軟でストレスなく拡大できるのかと
まあ例えば我々は物事を見る時は
自分の肉体だけ中心にして物事を見ているんですよ
単細胞のアメーバさんがサンといいますかね
私はサンといいますけどね
アメーバさんが自分の体のことで
周りほんのちょっとしか知らないんです
単細胞にも知る能力があるんで
生きてるんだから この細胞の脳は細胞膜なんです
細胞核には何も知る能力がないんです
私もちっちゃい時 勉強してる時の核がなんかすごい魂みたいな変なもんですねと思ったんだけど
本当はそうじゃないんです
細胞膜外 そこでリセプターというものがありまして
情報を受け取ると それから情報発信するものは結構たくさんあるんです
送信受信の能力はこの細胞膜にあるんです
だから細胞膜が脳なんです
単細胞アメーバさんの場合は
で アメーバさんが 知ってるのは自分がいる環境だけで
別に光があるとか 美しい花があるとか知ってる？知らない
昆虫も住んでいるんだよと
知らないね そこでアメーバ 40兆組み立てできているものだから
これもやっぱり自分のことしか知らない
それって心の失敗なんです
私とはこの肉体であると思って勘違いしているんです
だから私って本当に力がなくて弱いんだと
心っていうのはもうすごい広大なもので
もう何でもあれ 心とは知る機能だから
知ることに制限ないんです
知られることに制限ないんです
だから知る機能だけだったら何でも知り得るでしょう
これでなんかもう 檻を作っちゃって
檻の中に入っちゃって
鉄の玉を作っちゃって
その中に入っちゃって
ちっちゃな穴 ちっちゃな穴
そこから世の中見ていたってもね
バカじゃないんですかね
だからすっごい例えば太陽のように光を放す
放す何かあるとしましょう
それはもう鉄の玉の中に入れてロックする
して 針の穴ぐらい小さい穴だけ穴 5つぐらい開けておく
そうすると 我々のちっちゃな光の天使がないんですね
なんでそんなことをするのかと
肉体に依存して こうこうこうしちゃうと
もう知られるものの制限が消えちゃうんです
だから心の第1失敗はものに依存したことなんです
仏教から見れば ものも
心が作ったんです 心は物質を作るんです
この大宇宙がないんです
心がなければ だから心というのは
俺という単純なものじゃないんです
私という私の心って そんな何考えてるんですかね
膨大なものなんです でお釈迦様は物質は関係ないということはいくつか証明方法というのは見せたんですよ
物理に物質に依存している連中には
あんた方にこれできるのかいと
はい これは心が起きた
起こした巨大な問題で
物に依存するっていうことを始めたんですね
それから自分の能力 どんどんどんどん小さく小さくなっちゃっている
だから能力が小さくなればなるほど
知る範囲が狭くなればなるほど
この自由自在 広大無辺の心にとってはストレスがかかるんです
皆様今自由にいるんだけどね
もしすごい病気になって
体が動かなくなっちゃった
ご飯食べられなくなって
ベッドに寝ている 酸素をつけちゃって
栄養も点滴で あれって気持ち？気持ち悪いんです
自由がなくなったんです
それでストレスかかるんです
口と喉がなんとか食べなきゃ
まあイライラする でも食べられない状態で
ちょっとベッドから立ってちょっと動いたんだけど
あちらこちら管つけちゃって酸素つけてるんだから
これまたストレスですよ
だから自由がなくなるということ
活動範囲が狭くなればなるほど
ストレスになるんです
で 同時に硬くなるんです
今は我々は極限に硬い心を持って
極限にストレスの塊になって生きているんです
はい ではゆっくりと これはもう大きな問題だからね
どうやって解決していくのかという
私はこの瞑想する方々にある宿題というか
レッスンを教えるんですね
面白いことは みんななんか嫌な顔をするんですね
やらないと思いますけど
なぜかというと この愚かな心が何でもかんでも大胆なことでなければ
カッコ悪いと思っているんです
例えば 私はマインドフルネストレーニングというね
瞑想法をね 私はではなくて
仏教で 2500年もからずっと教えているんだけど
馬鹿にされるんですよ
それでアメリカでなんか神経科学の先生方がいろいろ調べたところでびっくりしちゃって
脳は改変できるんだとかね
だって勘違いしているんだから
脳は固定しているんだと
それで脳って肉体と同じく毎日変化するんだと
だったら病気でね 脳卒
脳何でしたっけ 脳出血
あれこれとかね 脳が壊れたら
なんで体の他のところみたいに修復できないんですかと
できるはずよと思ったんだけど
方法がない それでなんとか西洋でもアメリカでもイギリスでもテーラワーダ仏教を実践する人々は結構いるんだからね
本も書いたりしてね それはまあ宗教のことだからといってね
馬鹿にされていたんだけど
そこから方法を見つけたんですね
それを今流行っているマインドフルネスというね
日本でもグーグルなんか
なんと私あまり知らないんだけどね
それで興味持ったりして
この間もなんかのお坊さんたちの学会に行ってきたんだけどね
学会って言わない その場合は
このマインドフルネスとシカンタさの関係とかね
私は腹が立つんですよ
あの連中が言ってからあんた方気づくんですかと
これ 私たちは 2500年も持っていた財産でしょうに
なんで見なかったんですかと
だから この人間の心のバカらしさ
西洋で湾曲してお金に変換して売り物にしなきゃありがたく思わない
だから私はこの教えてるレッスンもすごく軽なっているように見えるので感じますからね
私の能力範囲はちょっと広いんです
申し訳ないんだけどね
言わなきゃわからないってこと
私の場合はないんです
言わない方がわかります
そこで 昔からの仏教の世界で
極端なシンプルな訓練で心をリラックスさせて柔軟させて
どんどん拡大して 肉体の制限を破って
それから何にも依存しない心に達するまで訓練するんです
全てすごいシンプルな方法なんです
だから皆様方はやるかやらないか
皆様の自由ですから まず私は言うのは
あの この折り紙でもティッシュ 1枚でもいいんだから
落ち着いて 過去のこともなく
将来のことも考えないで
実況中継しながら気持ちよくそれを折ってみてくださいと
ティッシュを まあティッシュの方がいいんですよ
折るのは難しいんですよ
折ることは折り紙だったら折るための紙だからね
折れますけど そこを半分に折ってみる
実況するんです あの 何て言いますか
手でストレッチングするとかね
それからまあまあ 折る
折る 置く 置くとか何とかとかね
適当な動作で実況しながら折ってみてください
しかし 決まりは完璧に 2つに折ってみてください
そこでポイントは 過去はどうでもいい
将来はどうでもいい このティッシュを折ることに
この折り紙を折ることに集中する
それから集中するために実況するんです
取ります 上げます 折ります
折ります 押します 押します
押します 押します 合わせます
合わせますと それで完璧にティッシュを 2枚に折る
そこでうまくいったら喜びを感じてください
うまくいったと リラックスを感じてください
それから じゃあ 4つにもう一回
折ってみる 同じ実況中継で
で うまくいかない場合は
まだまだもう一度 もう一度直して
直して直して 丁寧に すごい真剣に 4つに折ってみるんです
ぴったしと角がしっかりとあるようにと
しかし 過去はない 将来はない
だから実況して身を守らなくちゃいけないんです
身を守るで心を守らなくちゃいけない
それで 4枚に折れたら完璧にあー完璧やといったら喜んでみてください
うまくできたと 次 8枚になるように折ってみたらどうですかね
そうすると結構大変ですね
いいんです 悩まない  8枚の
たら折れるんだけど ぴったし完璧美しくは折れない
なるほど そういうこと
でも自分がギリギリできることはやったんだ
精一杯 ごまかったわけじゃない
手抜いたわけじゃない
しかし イメージしたものとは合わない
あ そういうこともあり得るんだ
言ってリラックスする
この訓練をやってみていくと
すぐ心がリラックスするんです
硬い心が柔らかくなるんです
すごく楽しくなるんです
何にもないところから
それから そういうものすごいシンプルな
ものでしか心を育てることはできません
難しいことをやっちゃうと
心が妄想だらけで 汚れで
感情で壊れるんです 例えばパソコン
コンピューターのプログラマーがいる
その人にはそこでやれたいろんなことを考えて考えて
この最近のプログラムというのは一人じゃないくてね
グループでやってます
みんな仕事を分担してもらって
セクション セクション
セクションやってみて
それを伸びたらまたつなぎてみて
またやってみてとかね
それでも最終結果がダメなんですね
OS なんかはいつでもバージョンアップ
バージョンアップでもキリがない
そういうことをやると精神的に壊れてしまいます
しかし 心がアホだ バカだからわかってないことがありまして
すべての物事はシンプルな出来事の組み立てなんです
一切難しいことは突然起きません
瞬間 瞬間 シンプルなことが起きて
起きて起きていくだけですね
そこは誤解しているんです
我々の心が 心が思うことは何でも間違いだから
まあしょうがないんですね
だから私は今教えて説明した
このティッシュを折ることは
なんだ こんなくだらんことやりたくないという気持ちが生まれているでしょ
まあアウトですね 幸せになる権利はないんです
私も責任じゃないんですよ
知ったことでありません
この極端なシンプルであることを喜べない人にとっては
喜びの権利さえないんです
この禅道場なんか行ってみたら
みんなびっくりするでしょう
すごいこと 何のこともないんで
すごいシンプルなことをやってるだけなんです
座布団を置く場合は正しく置くだけ
総研を取る場合は正しく取るだけ
すごいシンプルです 最終的に結果がすごいかもしれませんだけど
はい このティッシュを折る訓練してからリラックスしてまだ足らないならば
もう一つすごい簡単な方法があります
例えば 手を握る 握って実況中継しながら
小指をね ゆっくり伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす すごいスローですごい集中するんです
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす それから次のなんとか指ですね
それを伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばせるところでいいんです
無理をする ただぴったしこうする必要はないんです
普通はまあ ここら辺で伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす あの微妙な動き感じてください
それから真ん中の指をね
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 目を閉じて微妙に感じてください
伸ばす 伸ばす 実況しなきゃアウトです
心に影響入りません で
人差し指もやって それからなんとか指も伸ばしてみる
それから縮んでもみる
同じく これにはだいたい 5 分ぐらいかかりますよ
5 分でものすごく心がストレスがなくなっちゃって
安らぎを感じるんです
こんな簡単なことをあるのにやらないのは
まあ心はバカだから 皆様はバカじゃないんだけど
心がとんでもないバカなんですね
すごくストレスが固まっちゃってね
もうそうやられてしょうがない時は
ちょっと指一本ゆっくり伸ばしてゆっくり縮まってみる
そういう風に体を動かしてみる方法で
心が整理整頓されて落ち着いていくんです
そこでこの大胆なことではなく
なんとなく気持ちよかっただけで十分です
ちょっと気持ちよかったと
そういうことはまたちょっと難しいことを言います
我々は瞬間瞬間 何やっても心がそれを学ぶんです
それは避けられないんです
心がものを依存して物事を動かしているんです
動かしながら その結果を自分にフィードバックする
これ 意識じゃないんです
例えば私 今喋ってるでしょ？私の意識で使って喋ってますけど
同時に手を動かしたり
こうやったり いろんなことをやってますね
これは心がやってるんです
そういうものは心に全部記録されます
一つ残らず なぜ記録するのかというと
次のアクションがこの記録によって判断するんです
次どうしますか？ということを決めるために
今の経験が必要なんです
だから それを参照にするために
必ず  1 秒の 100分の1000分の単位で
我々の生きることの経験が脳にすーっとフィードバックされているんです
それで次の動き 次の動き
次の動きが決めるんです
はい それでよかったわけじゃないんですけど
なぜかというと 心は次の動きを判断すると
またいつでもロングサイン
データがあるんだけど
データをちゃんと調べて判断はしますけど
判断が間違っている 例えば裁判でね
この A さんが人を殺したことは証拠全部そろっている
揺らがない証拠はそろっている
したがって あなたは無罪にするという判断なんです
これでおかしいでしょうに
心はいつも間違った判断をするんです
間違った判断をすることにも
やっぱりデータを参照しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから心は何でも覚えておくんです
皆様の知識で思い出せないということは理由になりません
皆様 すべて考えてやっていますかね
手を上げることを下げること
お箸を取ること ご飯を食べること
水を飲むこと 呼吸 すること
全部ここから心がやってますよ
考える必要ないんです
例えば私はここら辺見て
このペットボトルを取ろうすると取れない
あ これ取っちゃったね
すぐ直すんで考えないで
これ取った途端もう判断行ったでしょ
あ これが違う これと だから心と恐ろしい速さで思考しないでやってるんですよ
はい そういうわけで 心は一度たりとも成功したという経験がないんです
それは他人のせいだと思ってるんです
私はそれ変えるんです
どうやって変えるかというと
紙を 2枚折ってみて あ
うまくいったと 脳にちょっとフィードバックしてあげるんです
脳ではなくて心に そこで心は落ち着くでしょ
一度たりともうまくいったことがない心が
そこを続けていくんです
うまくいってる うまくいってるというね
その脳にそういう正しいフィードバックするループを作らなくちゃいけない
これ 脳は後ですぐ変わりますからね
で 脳でっちはいけません
心がね はい それからもう一つっていうのは
この あの 私は元に戻すっていう言葉使ってますね
例えば自分の家で まあこうまあ
リビングにテーブルがありますね
テーブルの上に 例えば何か人が飲んだ水を飲んだガラスがある
そうすると 実況中継でこのガラス様を自分の家に戻してあげるんです
整理整頓するんじゃなくてね
ガラス様が迷子になっている
それで手を伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 取る 取る 取る 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 置く 置く
置くと 置いてみてください
実況中継で あるいは逆に間違った妄想思考で
あ これ片付けなくちゃいけない
誰がこっち水を飲んだったら
もう自分で片付け なんだこりゃ
これって地獄の生き方でしょ
なんのことない ガラス様が迷子になっている
で ガラス様が自分が住むべき家に戻してあげて
ガラス様は気持ちよくそちらに行って
あ よかったと自分が穏やかさを感じてください
で サッシ様を見つけたら
それもサッシ様がいるべきところに戻してあげてください
その訓練どうですか？とやらなきゃ意味がないんだけど
びっくりするほど精神的にリラックスしちゃって
ただ何もないのに楽しい生き方が出てくるんです
すごい柔軟になっていくんです
だから余計なくだらないことをやめてください
どっかドハド派手なこと
洋画教室に行かなくてもね
それよりすっごい精神的な安らぎを得られますよ
家の中にあるものは 迷子になっているものをね
これずつれ囲む品物を自分の家に戻しておく
それからもう一つ いろんなプログラム言えますよ
アレンジという言葉があります
アレンジ アレンジする
それで皆様よく知った顔をするんだけど
そのアレンジじゃないんです
それは欲で作ったアレンジなんで
花のアレンジとかね フラワーアレンジメントというのは稼働ですね
そういう欲で舞台ね ステージアレンジメントとかね
こんな妄想してイメージ作って
イメージに無理やり物事を動かすことなんです
それじゃないんです それは間違った心の世界なんです
もうちょっと高度なアレンジメントなんです
どういうことかというと
うん 今こちらに出せる例がないんですね
例えば自分ボールペンがある
ボールペンがある ずっと手で持つわけじゃなくて
置いておかなくちゃいけないでしょ
そこでボールペン様がいるべき形で
いるべき姿で気持ちよく置いてください
それだけ 包丁を取って何か切るでしょ
切ったすぐ次でポイと捨てちゃって
焦って次の仕事に行く
で 心が痛むんですね そこでもう包丁でもう玉ねぎでも切ったら包丁を置いとかなくちゃいけない
その時 アレンジして 包丁の形に合わせてしっかりと置いておいてください
それを喜んでください
切れるところはどんな方向にするか
取るところはどんな方向にするのかどうかね
そうすると滑ったり落ちたりはしませんよ
そのアレンジメントなんです
なんか即席では几帳面
なんとかという単語を使ってますけど
まあそれはちょっとちょっと暗い言葉かもしれませんだけど
そうじゃなくて 楽しく明るく
すごい楽しいんですよ
例えば服を脱いでパッと捨てちゃう場合は
もうストレス溜まってるんですよ
あれ 嫌々でやってるんですね
だからもう心がもう傷つくんですよ
それから捨てた自分も本当は気持ち悪いんですね
シャツを脱いでポイと捨てた自分も
その時チェックしていくと
心が怠けている イライラある
焦っている 気持ち悪い
幸福じゃない だからシャツを脱ぐのはシャツ様なんですよ
シャツ様をちゃんと 1つ
2つ  3つ脱いで綺麗に置いておく
これはこのまま洗濯に行くならば
そちらに置いておく それでまた使うんだったら
もうハンガーにかっこよく入れてまたかけておく
その時実況した方が瞑想にもなりますが
なんとなくこのシャツ様という気持ちになってくると
もうシャツ様は居心地よくしてあげるという風にね
そうやっていろんなものをアレンジしてみてください
これで智慧が現れますよ
初めから心が無明で無知で生きてるんです
こういうことをやってくると
なんか今だかって気づかなかったことに智慧が現れてくるんですよ
いろいろ それからこのちょっとみんなゲームでやっていることがあるんですね
あの あの木をこうやっていろいろ組み立ててから引っ張ったりするとかね
だからまあ そういう風に
この 例えばガラスをどうピラミッド型にアレンジするとかね
そういうのはゲームだから
あんまりまあこの心を成長させる
ストレッチする訓練に
あまり使わない方がいいんですね
なぜかって何か組み立てて組み立てて
上に上に上に丁寧に置いておくといきますよ
言うんだけど やがてぐらっと倒れちゃうと
あ 失敗やとね ゲームでやってる場合は
木は何とかゲームありますね
木を上に上に組み立てて組み立てていって
それで最後にやっぱり全部ダラダラと壊れちゃうと
あ あなたの負けっていうことになるんですね
それが心には良くないですね
だから この勝ち負けなりふてないところでアレンジメントという修行をした方が
心がすごく安らぎを感じるようになります
こういうのは本当は修行なんですよ
うん もう一つあります
これ自我というね とんでもない錯覚をなくすためにね
で まあ何か悩んで苦しんでストレスかかってるけど
何か生き物が目に入っちゃうでしょ
いっぱいいるんだから
生き物はね 何か生き物を見て狙って
これも生きているもので
こちらも生きているもので
同じ仲間やと 同じ生きている仲間やと
壁にちっちゃな蜘蛛を見つけたら
あるいはちっちゃななんとか昆虫を見つけたら
あ 生きている生き物だ
生きてるんだ 私も生きてるんだという
そこでこの自分が別なものではなくて
つながってるんだと感じてみるんです
それで生命とつなげると気分がいいんです
それで他の他の このみんな生きてるんだということを感じられるような生命体としてやってみてください
すごくすぐ楽しくなっちゃうんです
はい そこをできたら人間には人間めんどくさいんだけどね
一番最低の生き物だから
で 人間にとってもね まああの可愛いとかではなくて
みんな私と同じく同じ環境で頑張って生きてるんだと
私も失敗したくないし
この方も失敗したくないし
物事をうまく運びたいと私も思ってるし
この人も思ってるし ですから
まあ同じやと上司に怒鳴られる時でも
まあ私は怒鳴られてほしくなくて
うまく仕事をしたいんだけど
失敗するし まあ上司も結局は自分の仕事をやりたいと一生懸命頑張ってるんだ
大変やと この人も怒鳴られる
怒鳴られる私も大変で
怒鳴ってる この人も大変だなとかね
そこで誰が正しい 誰が間違ってるってことを使わない
バカな話です それは だって誰の心もロングサイト見ているんだから
例えば試験でみんな0点だったら
その中で誰が1にする？あ
この子は一番いいんですよと
点数は0点で判断できんでしょう
それは 10点  20点  80点
90点だったら一番頭いい子はと言えますよ
そうすると 98点取った子が一番頭が良くて 10
点の子はあんたダメですね
そこすごく苦しい世界が生まれるでしょ？差別世界が
みんな0点だから 別に人生においては
生きることにおいては
だから自分をもう無批判的にガンガン怒鳴怒鳴っている上司も
人生は0点です 仕事を失敗してうまくいかなかった自分も
人生は0点なんです だから上司が悪いって言えないでしょうに
だからそうやって人に大変だ
私はこれ この子供を操っているお母さんたちを見ると
お母さんも大変だけど
子供ギャーギャー泣いて
特に飛行機に乗った場合は
この着陸するときはどんな母ちゃんもギャーッと泣くんですね
離陸するときも泣く子供いるんだけど
着陸する場合は これは決まってるんです
でもお母さんにとってはどうするも立ってはいけないし
ベルトで体と留めておかなくちゃいけないし
赤ちゃんがいるとちゃって泣いてるし
そこで困っているのは赤ちゃんも困ってる
だって空気圧が上がっちゃうでしょ
着陸すると だから子供の耳が痛くなっちゃって
真ん中の耳炎っていうところね
すごい痛いんですよ だから子供にとって泣くしか方法がない
大人だったらこの空気を抜くことをわかってできますけど
だからお母さんどうする？お母さんも困っていて
だからそこでお母さん悪い
ちゃんと子供の泣いてるの泣き止ませてくださいって
そんなこと言える？言えないでしょ
だからあなたもあなたもバスで乗りたい
昔 お茶新宿駅でこのすごい人いるところでささっと行く場合は
このあるお母さんとちっちゃな子供なんですね
どこかディズニーランドとかで行って遊び遊んで帰ってる途中だと思いますけど
ディズニーランド大人もくったくた疲れますよ
それで子供も疲れますよ
それで子供が抱っこしなさい
抱っこしなさいとお母さんに言うんですね
泣きながら抱っこ抱っこって
でお母さんがもう抱っこできないもう疲れちゃって
だから子供がわがままと言える？わがままと言えないで
疲れているんだから お母さんが悪いと言える？言えないでしょうね
お母さんもくったくた疲れているんだから
お母さんがもうちょっとで電車に乗りますからね
もうちょっと頑張ってよとか言っているんだけど
子供にそんなのわからないでしょ
だからこの世の中で このこの白黒と分けることをやめたらどうですかね
だからその訓練してみてください
生命を 虫を選んで 昆虫を選んで
木の枝に座っている鳥を見て
じーっと見て あ 生きてるんだとかね
私も同じく生きているんだとかね
自分が窓部屋の中から見ているんだから
私がやっぱり暖かいところにいなきゃダメだけど
この鳥さんが全然寒さに大丈夫みたいだとかね
この間どこかで私もちょっとした普通
普段見たらなんか色のよくある鳥ですけど
木の枝のトップのところで立っていて
体綺麗にするんですね
それを見ていると まあ私たちもいつでもこうやってくちくやって綺麗にするし
これも同じことやっている
それで面白いことは 人間というのは体を洗う時は肉体の癖があって
まあ洗うところは毎回洗うんだけど
洗わないところは毎回忘れちゃう
ですね で あの鳥さんを見ていると
こちら見てるから右側の翼をすごくやってやって
そこでもう下の方やっちゃうと
ザーッとその右側の翼だけ広げちゃうんです
そうすると慣脳で尾っぽの翼もきっとあのあれの
なんとかの感じで美しく広げちゃいますけど
この左側は何もないんです
私はそればっかりやらないで左でやってくださいと思ったんだけど
やらないんですよね こちらばっかりでやってるんで
だからそこでなんと楽しくない？右の翼だけ切るんです
これまたすごい真剣で
もうたまたま小さいところが真剣にやってると
自動的に翼だけ 1本一つだけ広げちゃって
同時に尾っぽもパッと広げちゃって
すごい綺麗で そういう風にこの生命を選んで
この善悪判断なく 良い悪いの話がなく
我々はすごいストレスかかって心が硬くなっているのは
この良い悪い判断なんですよ
いつでもこれが良い これが悪い
これは失敗 これは成功
それ消す訓練しますよ
1 日では消せませんから
ゆっくりと 例えば 朝 雨が降っていたんだけど
ああ 雨が降ってるんだから
もうなんで夜によって今日はと思っちゃうと
もう悪いと判断しているでしょ
そうすると心にストレスかかっちゃうんです
ああいう微妙なところのストレスを感じてください
ド派手なストレスじゃないんで
このちっちゃなところで
このほんのわずかな 光の 1粒のような感じでストレス溜まっていくんです
ですから この次のレッスンというのは
このちっちゃなところで善悪判断が割り込んじゃって
ストレスかかっちゃう
だから雨が降ってるんだから
じゃあ傘をさして行きましょうと
それでちょびちょびと濡れちゃったら
あ 嫌だこれはとかね 嫌だからそこでもうストレスかかっているんです
はい そういうことで 生命を観察する方法でも
心がどんどん広くなって
柔軟になって拡大して大きい心になるんです
そこで一人 二人  3人  4人選んだりして
家族はみんな一緒やと思ったりして
どう見ても一緒の同じもんだからね
で どんどんどんどん広げて
もし生き物は誰だって結局は同じやと
ロングサイドを見て生きてるんだから
私だけじゃなくて みんないろいろやってるんだ
だからこれは私が あの人悪い
この人正しい 私が悪いと
そんな世界はないんだと
理解していってほしいんですね
次 次 ちょっと心にちょちょいと訓練させますね
ちょっと偏見持っちゃう
これって心にちょっといたって簡単だからね
初めから偏見だから この場合は
ビューティーというものを発見するんです
ビューティーちゃん美ですね
だからまあ 例えばガラス
ただのガラスでつまらないねではなくて
綺麗にできているんだとかね
結構綺麗だとか こちらに隠れている美を発見するんです
やったことないでしょ？私はやったことある
例えばこのただのペットボトルで皆さんにつまらないでしょ
私にとってはこの線が綺麗にできちゃって
これもこのラベルをね
ちゃんとデザインしてあって
まあよくできてますよ
作品として こんなもん喜んで見てください
ペットボトル見て 例えばこの会社はこんな形でしょ
別な会社のペットボトルだったら別なデザインなんですよ
それで裏はどういう風になっているのかとかね
よく見るとよくできてますね
これ楽しくならない？ですから
次のレッスンはファインダビューティー
ということなんです これ金かかりませんよ
ペットボトルで十分です
金かかって あのー あちらに行っちゃえば
どこでしたっけ？あの
いろいろギャラリーとかね
あの連中はもうストレスかかっちゃって苦しみを作ってるだけ
ギャラリーに行って絵画を見るどうかね
あれバカです ストレスかかるだけではなくて
心にあるもので だからこのちょっとしたその角度でね
美を発見するんです どんなところに行っても
どこに行ったってそういう風に
で あのもう電車に来たんだから
もしちょっとストレスがあるとかね
ちょっと落ち着きがないと言ったら
全然大丈夫ですよ 自分の前にある座席の脇見たら
そちらに美があるんです
あのなんか座席はなんか布で布というんですかね
アプローチしてますけどね
あのデザイン あの色 あの色が合ってるのかどうかね
当然ものすごく合ってますよ
電車のつり革がどうやってできているのか調べたことがある？どんな風なねじって留めているのかどうか
いろいろですよ で そこをよくできているなとかね
全然金がかからない 前の座席を電車で乗っていて見ていて
この美しさを喜ぶんです
見てください そうなってくると
世界は全部美一つになっちゃうんです
その人に嫌な気持ちが生まれると思う
何を見ても美しいんだから
何を見ても美しいんです
はい それからさらに心を自由にしたければ
私はこのレンズを変える
フォーカスを調整するという言葉 2つ使いたいんですね
ものの見る時のレンズを変えてみる
眼鏡を変えてみる だからやっぱりまずはこの美を見る目
一番大事なんですね そこをできたら
あまり感動したっても面白くないんだから
もう冷静な目で見るとかね
そういうレンズを変える
それからでっかく見る
ワイドアングルで ワイドアングルで見て
それから小さいマイクロアングルで見る
例えばこのままベッタベタワイドアングルで見ると
それなりに美しさは見える
では この蓋だけ取ってみてください
それもものの見事にできているんです
そういうことでレンズを変えたりして
ものの見方のね で 自由自在になってみてください
一つに偏ってはいけない
例えば富士山をワイドアングルで見ると美しいんですよ
狭い ちゃんと合わせてみると美しくないんです
ただの小倉の山なんです
そういう風に 例えば下から雲を見るとワイドで見えますね
美しく見える で 飛行機に乗ってそこへ通っていくと
ただ飛行機もガタガタするだけで
もう霧を通してるだけなんですね
美しくない 高度上がったら下を見るとまたワイドで見える
そのように心の見方の訓練というのは難しくないでしょうにね
はい 次の訓練が 私はこの電車でササッとメモを書いちゃったんだからね
これ英語で書いちゃったんだから
どうやって日本語にするのか今困ってますけどね
すべてインターステラーで
互いにこのネットワークで
この何といいますか つながってます
えっと では このスクリーン見ると周りがちょっと暗いんですね
この周りが暗いだからこそ
このスライドが見えるでしょ？だからこれ助かってますよ
だから周りが暗くなってよかったね
で もうちょっと明るくしましょうと思っちゃうと
スライドが見えなくなっちゃうでしょ？だからそういう風に
互いにこの正反対のものが組み合わさっちゃって成り立っているんです
それを発見すると結構リラックスできるんです
だから ものはいつでもいろんなものにつながっているんですね
単独で独立してドカーンと出ることはできません
ドカーンと出て驚かせる場合も
最初は何もない状態が必要なんですよ
そういうことで 自分の命も他の命につながっている
だから自分一人勝手では動けませんよ
この調和っていうものをね
そうやってこの大自然の
このインターステラーっていう
互いに えっと まあそれぞれ関係あって成り立っているんだっていうこと
で発見する方法もあります
それがこの自分の人生になってくると
自分が暗くなっちゃったと
それが俺の勝手っていうことはないんです
自分の命が周りと大自然とすべての生命につながっているんです
巨大な無限のネットワークにつながっているんですね
そこで自分というところが落ち込んじゃっちゃうと
あのネットワークがちょっとバランスが
バランスが崩れるんです
それはチェックしてください
いわゆるわがままで自分勝手で生きていきたいでしょ
それは long サイト見ているんです
わがまま好き勝手は初めからもうないんだと
それは発見してほしい
だって私はこの服着てるんだけど
私のわがまま好き勝手にそれ着ることできないんで
この肉体に合わせなくちゃあかんだから
だからどう着るべきかっていうことはもう決まってるんですね
帽子は靴下の代わりに使えないでしょ
帽子はまあ現れたら もうこの大宇宙存在の中でどちらに行くべきかって決まっているんです
いるべきかと それで心も同じなんですね
私の心の状況はすべての心が繋がっているんだから
これじゃないんですよ
自分が悪い波長を持ってしまうと
他の心が全部そっち そちらに合わせちゃうんですね
合わせちゃって 大変なことになります
例えば この 40兆の細胞で体ができているでしょ
外から 他の細胞が入り込んでくる
どうなる？このシステムには関係ない
破壊されますね 体に入ったらあんたは関係ないわと
だからこの体の中でたくさん生命が生きているでしょ
ものすごい大量に 細胞の数よりははるかにたくさんいますよ
微生物たちが なんでいますかというと
システムの中でうまく調和しているんですね
協力し合っているんですね
だから ストレスなく生きるためには
大自然とすべての生命と調和しなくちゃいけない
これって目的に達するために
何か何か何かとのつながっているんだということを面白いこと調べてください
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
はい そういうことで 次のステップは
あなたが落ち込んでいる場合は
あなたがストレスかかっている場合は
あなたが怒っている場合
あなた感情を出している場合は
あなたが大自然 大生命に迷惑をかけている
そちらからの反応で自分が潰れていくんです
これってすっごいキツいんです
だからいつでもそこを理解するんですね
私は落ち込んじゃったら
これが結構やられますよと
落ち込んだとは 他の生命と自然界を敵に回すことなんです
いや 私は勝手に落ち込んだんだけど
あんたに迷惑かけてないでしょ？思っちゃうでしょ
でないんですよ 落ち込んで怒りで憎しみである人は
水飲んでも水が敵に回しちゃうんです
水にとってはスムーズに自分の仕事ができないんです
ご飯食べてもご飯が 悪いことをしちゃうんです
だから自分のストレス
自分の落ち込み 自分の苛立ちなどなどが
自分の頑固さなどなどが
自分が敵を作ることになる
誰も悪くない 自分の心が悪いんです
そうすると これ直しちゃうとみんな一緒にいる仲間以外何でもない
これでお母さんと子供が仲間ですよ
それぞれ役割は違いますよ
子供がいろいろ世話してもらっている
お母さんがお世話してあげている
でもそれで嫌なことないでしょ
すごく幸せな関係でしょ
でも子供がすっごいもう怒るわ
喧嘩するわ ご飯あげても捨てるわ
あれやこれやっちゃうと関係が壊れちゃうんです
子供が敵を作っているんです
当然お母さんは怒るんです
何やってるのかと だから心が悪いんです
お母さんが鬼やって言ったってもね
ある男の子が言ったの
私はね お母さん鬼ですわ
あれやこれやとお母さんをからかってるんですね
私はじーっとこの戦いを見ていて
ちょっと問題がありますよと
私が知ってる範囲では
このお母ちゃんがお母さんのこと昔から知ってます
あなた方生まれる前から
すごく優しい人でしたよと
すごく明るくて優しくて
それからなんか鬼になったんですねと
これ誰がお母さんが鬼にしたんですかねとかね
子供だからといって私は真理そのまま言うんです
だからもう二人がいたんだ
二人もそれから黙っていたんで
あの芸はやめたんです
お母さんが鬼やということを
それから私たちはこの小さな小さな失敗に対して
すごく嫌っていう気持ちが生まれるんですね
これが大人なんです どんどん気づかない
あのちっちゃなところで嫌と思うところが気づかないんだけど
溜まっちゃうんですね
例えば何か加工するとボールペンが滑っちゃって落ちる
なんか嫌と思わないんだけど
またそれをこうやってさかんで取りますけど
その時気をつけてください
なんのことなく 取り方がうまくいかなかったんだからね
じゃあ落ちたと じゃあこれで拾いますと
で 何かとすると こうやって手がこっちにぶつかっちゃう
ぶつかったら痛くなる
あ 嫌だからではないね
あ 見なかったんだから
ぶつかって今痛くなっている
ああいう小さなところで嫌だなということを生まれないような訓練してみてください
これね 毎日この小さなところをチェックしなくちゃ
髭をする時とかね お風呂に入っている時とかね
お風呂の掃除をやっている時とかね
掃除機かけている時とかね
何かにもさい まあ嫌だこれはとかね
うまく掃除機かけられないんだからとか
あの気持ちが良くないんです
ああいうわずかなところでストレスが溜まって溜まって
末期状態になるんです
それからこの たまに たまにではなくて失敗しますよ
気にしないでください
失敗しても あんた何で失敗したからって世紀末じゃないでしょ？電車にちょっと乗り遅れたとか
だから別に何のこともないでしょ
約束に 5分遅れたとか
やっぱり約束に遅れるとすっごくそれ気になるんですね
私も結構遅れますけど
あの気になったところで心が硬くなって
ストレスが溜まっていくんですね
だから毎日見てみると
結構いろんなことを失敗しますけど
まあそんなもんやっていうことで落ち着いていれば
まあ大体失敗の数も少なくなるし
この世の中で失敗しない生命がいるわけじゃないしね
動物を観察している時でもね
結構失敗しますよ 動物の場合は何のことなく穏やかにいるんですね
何か獲物を捕ろうとしたら獲物に逃げられちゃうと
別に悔しいとかないんです
何のことなく出ていくんです
それ見て本当にびっくりしちゃったんです
鳥たちが餌を食べていて
何か出てくるとサッと逃げちゃうでしょ
鳥たちはせっかく食べてたのに邪魔されちゃってね
悩んでればそうじゃなくて
何のことなく飛んでいく
そこから学べるんですよ
いろんなことを起きるんだけど
別にそれで世紀末ってわけじゃないんだと
それからこの大胆な災害っていうのは毎日来るわけないんです
稀に来るんですよ だから毎日の災害はそんなに気にする必要はないんです
次の訓練というのは この
また日本語がなくなっちゃった
このアイドリングという言葉がありますね
車の場合でもね 我々はこの有効にいない時間というのは結構あるんですね
有効でない時間っていうのはストレスの層なんです
硬くなっちゃうんです
有効に時間を使わないとすごい危険なんです
これはアイドリングは良くないんです
あんまり真剣でも良くないんだけど
何かちょっと役に立つようにする
余った時間があったら
そこをなんとか楽しく明るくいるようにする
だから言葉で時間を無駄にしないことをね
無駄に時間したいんだけど
その間ではすごく心が硬くなっているんですね
やれ なかったらなんとかもう古い新聞でもいいんだから読めば
なんかそこら辺雑巾でも持ってちょっと拭いて拭いたりすれば
なんとかしてほしい よくよくするに
この無駄に過ごさないというね
で それからこの 有効に何でもやっちゃうと
なんか変ですね また やっぱり休まなくちゃいかんですよ
休むときはしっかり休んでください
気持ちよく だって仕事ばっかりじゃなくて
遊びもしなくちゃあかんでしょ？仕事をする時はもう仕事をする
遊ぶ時はとことん遊ぶというね
でなきゃ有効にならないんですね
遊ぶときは明日のことを考えちゃうと
何かプログラムを考えたりするとアウトですよ
遊んでないんです だから遊ぶ時間を用意して
遊ぶ時間で遊ぶ ゲームやる時間があったら
そこでとことん鬼のようにゲームやればいいんです
人生一生ゲームやってもいいけないだけのありそうなんですね
音楽を聴く場合はみんな 24 時間で聞いてる
私はあれがすごく嫌なんですね
歩く時でももうイヤホンつけたままで
どちら何やっているのかと
私は歩くときは歩くことは完璧にやるんです
全部見ながら もうそこでいろんなことを観察しながら
今皆さんに言ったこと
全部私はやっているんです
だからいつでも頭が活性化して
何かいつでも面白いものが入ってくるんですね
今日来る時 こちら来る時でも
部屋出てから周りは一切見ないということにして
自分があるいてをする
自由の瞑想しながら歩いたんですけど
その思考だけで行くんだ
外とかね それでいっぱい人々が行ったり来たりするんだけど
私にとってはカットする時のあの経験
得られるのです 逆に全部見ようと思っちゃうと
それもとことんやる するとすごいきめ細かく見えるんです
はい そして友達作ってください
一人でいることはね ストレスの塊になるんです
一人で生活はできません
一人の命っていうのは絶対ないのです
我々は心が間違っています
私は私で一人で生きているんだ
そんな生命はないんです
つながったことで生命になっているんです
だから あえて人間だから友達を作った方が心が軽くなります
友達がいないんだったら
まあ見ると動物たちでもペットでも
まあそこから始めればいいんですね
まあ生命にやっぱり触れることなんですね
それからこの 友達作ることでみんな失敗するのは
この自家製友達作る 自分の利益のために
そうすると敵同士の関係になるんです
友達じゃないので お互いに何かもう血を吸ってやるぞと
血を吸う同士の関係ですよ
世間の友達関係っていうのは
これはちょっと問題が起こりますね
ではなくて この英語の言葉というのはエンパシーという言葉があるんですね
皆さんはシンパシーという言葉はよく日本語でも使いますね
あまりエンパシーという言葉を使っていないんですね
エンパティというのは
この何といいますか この
シンパシーというのは
相手のことをわかってかわいそうやと思うことで
それではなくて エンパシーっていうのは何でしたっけね
共鳴する 一緒に一緒の波長になる
まあ日本語では人のことをわかるって
気持ちわかるというね
という程度のことなんですね
だからあんた 人のよくわかりますよという態度じゃないんですね
この無意識 考えない心で感じてくるんですね
あの気持ちを 時々私は人間悪いんだから
皆さんは質問したりする場合は
相手もあまり単語がね
サッと喋らない場合もありますから
何質問して何知りたいかとわからなくなっちゃう場合もあります
私の場合 それはその瞬間で遠隔使うんです
使って その心と一緒にちょこっと橋を作ってみたら
これはもう 1 秒の 100 分の1でできます
あ これ知ったかってるんだ
これはわかるんです そういうことで友達を作ったりして
でも相手の気持ちいいね
好き嫌いっていうのは
そこからは理解する ここから理解するんじゃなくてね
その相手の立場から理解するっていうね
するとすごい心が広げてリラックスしますよ
で まあまあ そろそろまあこの話はやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと
時間的にはもう時間も終わっちゃったね
最後に行かないで済むみたい
で 次のポイントは今の瞬間楽しみましょう
今の瞬間 これ 心がわからないんですね
心がいつでもロングサイト見ているんだから
実際は今の瞬間しかないんです
何するでも今の瞬間でやるでしょ
昨日 明日はもうただの観念だけでしょ
だから今の瞬間見ると面白いんです
何も問題ないんです 例えば
私がすごく今悩んでるんだと
聞いてみてくれ なんで過去のことなんです
実は昨日 実はもう先日
実は小さい時とかね なんでアホかと
だって私のカウンセリングは至って簡単
まあいいんですけど 今
今の瞬間であなたの悩みなんですか？って
それ解決してあげますよと
今の瞬間で そしたら今の瞬間では別に
あ そう じゃあていうか
次の瞬間でないでしょ
うん 帰ってください そんな簡単ですよ
幸福できることは だから心がもう本当にアホだからわかってないだけ
我々の心のアメーバさんと何の変わりもない
だから今の瞬間生きるということは
もう強烈なアドバイスなんです
そこはもう過去に行った癖があるんだから
もう思い出して思い出して
今の瞬間だけしか生きれません
今の瞬間しか生きてませんとかね
繰り返し繰り返し念じながらでもこれ
ねじってください そうすると今の瞬間にやってしまいます
それから今の瞬間喜んでください
別に大したことないんだからね
今の瞬間に喜びを感じたら
その人が本当に喜びを感じるんです
この講演が終わってからご飯を食べて楽しみましょうと思っちゃう人はかわいそう
それ これを無理やりやらなくちゃいけない
私の心が勘違いしちゃって
私がいると思っているんです
これ 科学的に見ても私がいるわけじゃないんです
脳科学者たちがどこでセルフという気持ちが生まれるのかと
もう脳の細胞を調べてみて
ないんだと発見しているんです
ないんだったらなんでこれは？というと
そこでやっぱり仏教が言ってる心の存在を認めないためになっちゃったんです
じゃあ心が私ですかというと
それは科学者に心の研究できんだからね
心は同じこっちゃ だからこの肉体はできている物質はこの地球の物質でしょ
私 私の特別な炭素があるわけないでしょ
私 特別なカルシウム これはこのカルシウム
私だけのもの あなたのカルシウムと違いますと
あり得る？ないでしょうに
これ 細胞で見ると遺伝子で見る
違うかもしれませんだけど
骨の骨の中いっぱいカルシウムあるでしょ
これはもう海岸にあるカルシウムも同じものなんです
だから私の特別なものは何もないんです
あるんだったらご飯も食べられないでしょ
だから私の体にあるカルシウム
自然界にあるカルシウム同じものだから
カルシウムを含んでいる食べ物を食べちゃうと
そこは同じものを同じところに行っちゃいます
そういうことで 肉体はわかりやすい
心も同じなんです そういうわけで
私という気持ちではなく
すべての現象が流れるんだと
生命って海と同じだと
1滴1滴の塩を見ることも可能ですけど 1
滴の塩が海じゃないんだと
だからなんで自分が大海の中にいるのに
自分だけ一滴の水でしょ
俺が違いますよと言ったっても何かなる？大海をイメージしてみてください
それであなたは一滴 水一滴なんです
これで何かなる？一滴だと
外に出ちゃうと蒸発しちゃう可能性もありますね
だから生命が一つで流れるだけなんです
そこを理解すれば これもう今はもうレベルをかなり高くしています
私は はい もう一つ皆様に実践できることがあります
これ私は英語で書いたんだから
エンジョイザディファレンスなんです
エンジョイザディファレンス
違うことは楽しんでくださいと
これが自我のある間違った硬い心にはできないんです
似てなきゃもう仲間はずれにする
あんた違いますよと しかし
すべて違いますね この違いを楽しむとどこまで楽しめる？人間見ても一人一人違います
歳も違うし 性別も違うし
服も違うし 何から何まで違いますね
この違いを楽しむ これが知恵なんです
我々の心の違いは楽しめないんです
違いとわかった途端 もう拒否する
そこで私がやった実験なんて失敗しましたけどね
例えばアリがいるんですね
アリも 1匹1匹違うでしょ
うーん これ見なくちゃいかんねと
1匹1匹違う細やか なかなかアリが小さすぎちゃって
形も同じくてよくわからなくなったんだけど
でもやっぱり違うアリたちがいるんですね
同じアリの群れなんですけど
ちょこちょこいじってみると
それぞれ反応はまるっきり同じじゃないんです
私がよくやることは このアリがずっと日本ではできないんだけど
もう行列を作っていくんですね
アリは匂いで道を作るんですね
高速道路 だから私はアリがあっちのこっち行く間で
自分の指でこうやって拭くんです
指で拭いちゃうと 高速道路が壊れてるんですね
それでずっとアリが行って
カチッと あ 道路が終わっちゃったと止まっちゃうんですね
そこでいくつかのアリたちがそこでもうどんどんどんどん群れになっちゃうんですね
それでじーっと見ていると
一匹のアリがもういられなくて
ぐるぐるぐるぐるやったりするんですね
それでやっているともう一匹が向こうに行っちゃうんですね
もう一匹がまたまた向こうに行ったら
また道路ができちゃって
また行くんです だから
あのちっちゃなアリもみんなそれぞれ違うんだなと
そういうことで 花を見ると皆と同じじゃないんですよ
ものすごく頭が悪くて
まあバラの花でしょう
赤いバラちょうだい  10本ちょうだい
黄色いバラも3本ちょうだいとかね
で 見てください 一個一個違うんです
毎日食べるご飯 毎日違うんです
仏教用語で一期一会と言うんでしょ
同じご飯は一回しか食べられませんね
ご飯というと 一粒一粒また違うんですよ
この違いを楽しめると
きりがなく楽しめます
違いを認めると きりがなく落ち着きます
私はちょっとしたストレスない心を作ろうと思っていないんです
これ極限に極端にストレスのない心の道を教えているんです
そこで最後に違いを楽しむ
なぜならば 私の心がいつでも犯人は心でしょ
私の心が私を騙しちゃうんですね
騙してワンパターンやと
みんな同じやと だから欲しすぎなんで
人間が無常に反対なんですね
変化に反対なんですね
だからストレスかかっちゃうんですね
社会は変わっていくでしょうに
毎日世界が変わっていくでしょうに
これ認めたくない あーなんだこれはとかね
守らなくちゃとかね 何を守ってるんですかね
文化を守らなくちゃ 日本語も壊れていく
これ守らなくちゃとかね
何なんだよ 何も守る必要ないんです
全部変化するんだから
特に日本の坊さんたちはもう笑っちゃいます
この古くて今役に立たない伝統を守ってやる
勝手に守ってください
いらんやって こちらには
お坊さんたちの人が言ったんですね
道元禅師が時間多殺と言ったのが時間多殺とマインドフルネスはどうですかと
私はこれ違いますよと
時間多殺とは道元禅師
そういう言葉を使ったんだけど
それがこの悟りに対して
知ってる単語だと バカみたく座ってることじゃないんだと
いくら言っても あの腐った伝統でそう教えられてるんだから
だったら道元の言葉を読み直しちゃえばどうですかね
禅宗の僧侶なのに 道元はものを見事に五百五十年間誤解している
だから修行は別な あれ無執着ですね
信心脱落というところに単語を使って
それが修行であって 大学でもダラダラと横に張って教授たちが完璧真っ赤な間違いを言ってるんですね
私は笑ってますけどね
だからこの守るっていうことはありえないんです
守ることですごい大変でしょ
財産守るは 子供を守るは
国を守るは やってみてください
何か守られましたか？若さを守るは
何考えてるんですかね
だからこの心が私たちを騙しちゃって苦しませているんです
それから変化に適応できないということは怠けなんです
だから汝は守るべきものは何もないと
すべて変化するんだよと
私の仕事は変化に適応することだけ
それだけ それ以上自由がある
はい  最後のポイントは
このまあ あなたのアイデンティティを発見しなさいなんです
あなたは何ものかを発見してくださいと
できる？これって仏教で答えがあるんです
この間 どこか学校で先生たちに話した時は
この子供たちが この私はどういうものか
何者かという問題よく持ってきてるんだと
どう答えればいいか 私は先生
簡単に答えますと 子供たちは私はどんなどうすればいいか
何者がいたら 今の瞬間のあなたの精神的な状況が自分だよと
だから今どうするべきかとわかるでしょ
次の瞬間 瞬間はあなた別な人間だと
英語の言葉でエモーショナルセカンド
エモーショナル感情的
今の感情的な今の感情が自分です
そこで反応する ちょっと場所が変わったら違うんですね
今 このホールの中にいるでしょ
ドアを開けて外を出た途端
別な自分なんです だから言葉って自分とは存在しないとも言えるし
逆に瞬間瞬間自分が変化して変わっていくんだとも言える
だから皆様 例えば座ってるでしょ
試しに立ってみてください
自分が変わっちゃいます
立っただけで自分が変わっちゃいます
その自分を発見してください
すぐ変わる 固定した自分がいないんです
そうするとストレスは溜まるはずもないんです
だから私の仕事はなんなのかというと
今の自分で何するべきかなんです
それは難しくないでしょ
レストランに入って座ったら別な自分
レストランに入った時のまた別な自分
ただ レストランに入って立ったまんまでメニューを読む
読まない 読まない 注文する
しない 立ってる自分には
次の仕事は座る場所 店によって自分勝手に座ってもいいし
あるいは案内される場合もある
座ったら別な自分 座ってから
そうするとメニューを取ったり
雰囲気を喜んだり いろいろでしょ
注文した食べ物が来たら別な自分
ガキのように食っちゃうというね
ガキのように食いまくっちゃうんじゃなくて
そこを楽しんで 穏やかにその瞬間を喜ぶ
そうやって自分というのは瞬間瞬間変化する
その瞬間に対応するだけで
ストレスが溜まるはずがないんです
心が間違ってるだけ はい
そういうわけで 私たちはよく失敗するところは
この過去に引っ張られることですね
死んだ過去 だから過去は実在しない
存在しない だから派手な言葉で言います
この腐ってる遺体を背負わないでくださいと
はい 瞬間瞬間自分が死ぬでしょ
死んだ死体を死体無数に背負っているんです
臭いのは当たり前でしょうに
死んだ死体を捨ててください
我々そうでしょう たとえお母様であろうが
死んじゃったら捨てるでしょ
だから私が無数に過去で死んだ私を背負っている
これ生きてない もう死体だけ腐るだけ
そういうことで 過去に引っ張られることをやめて
今の瞬間に生きるということは
究極の心の安らぎでございます
時間的にどうなってますかね？今は 4時11分ですね
あと 20 分ぐらいは  20 分ぐらい
じゃあこれやりましょうか
ここでまあ 正しいとか説明することはできなくなる
そんなのは別に説明しない
はい じゃあもうやりましたね
心の一片拡大するところ
そこまでやりました えーと
はい こっちはちょっと物語を書きます
これは私はあんまり仏教的じゃないんだけどね
あの なんとなく物語感覚
最初に最初っていうのは仏教ではないんですけどね
ちょっと他宗教からこれパクっちゃったんです
もう他宗教というよりも
この最近の神経科学に本書いてる先生たちのね
まあエリートたちのね
説明ってちょっと僕では間違ってるの知ってますけどね
最初は心はなんでしたっけ？際限なく大宇宙空間よりももう無限に広げていると思ってください
自分の心があまりにも広大無辺な心であったと
はい で そこはあの 例えば空気がありますね
空気といったらものすごいでしょう
自分というのはこの空気の分子一個なんですね
しかし 空気は分子一個で何もできる
何かできる 何もできません
やっぱり空気は空気でなきゃ
あの偉大なる力ができないんです
何かの形になって固定したくなったんで
心が失敗するんです 何かこの形も何もない
何も形は取ってない状態では
ちょっと困った 何か形取った方が安定するんじゃないと勘違いしちゃうんです
有限の宇宙になってみても
不安定でさらに小さくなっていきます
そこで語りちゃった途端
小さくなっちゃうんです
だから宇宙が現れてくる
それで それでまたどんどんどんどん小さくなっていく
やっぱり心が形取って安定したいんだけど
どんどん小さくなって不安になっていくんですね
だから 例えば私の 宇宙的
宇宙の範囲に広がっているといったらすごい不安定で
やっぱりこの太陽系にしようかなと思ったら小さくて安定するようですけど
不安になっちゃうんです
どんどんどんどん今の体になっているんです
だから今人間になってますけど
不満なんですね 不安です
さらにものに執着 そこで人間になった我々は不安だから落ち着きたいんです
そこでものに執着する
動物よりも派手に建物を作ったり
服を買ったり 金をもらう
そこでさらに不安になるんです
それから さらに自分を小さくするために
怒り 嫉妬などなど感情まで作って
自分別 自分が自分が別やと思っちゃうんです
これ 自然法則に逆らっているんだから
決していい結果にはならないんですね
例えば 嫉妬する人はそれで自分が安定すると思っているんです
みんなわかるで なんでそんな嫉妬するのかと
放っておいて放っておけないんですね
例えば自分の奥さんがね
自分の旦那がね 不倫しちゃったとバレちゃう
バレたところからもう怒りで
嫉妬で憎しみ 放っておきなさいよと
そしたら何言うのかと
できないんです やっぱり自分を小さくしちゃうんです
もともと自由自在でしたので
何か違うと薄々感じていますが
今それはわかりません
我々なんかわかって なんか違う
なんか違うなとね 金があれば幸せよと
なんかそれでも違うね
結婚したら幸せになる
でもなんか違う じゃあ子供が生まれたら？生まれるんだけど
なんか違うね いつでもそれを感じているんです
薄々 でも我々はそこを不安感じちゃうと
もうちょっと何者か品物を持ってくるんです
子供が生まれ幸せなんですけど
なんか不安になってくる
子供のおもちゃを買ってくる
でもなんか違う それはみんな心ももよだからわかってない
もともと心は自由自在だったから
今自由自在 自分で意図的に壊しているでしょ
だから走り回っていた自分が面白いそうと言って鎖を見つけて
あの足にかけて 面白くてロックするんですね
ロックするんだったら
あの結んじゃうとかっこ悪いんだから
これ溶接しましょうと
そこで鎖を気持ちよく溶接するんですね
うまくできたと うまくできたんだけど
何か違うんじゃない？それから動かなくなっちゃうんですね
心の気持ち 何かに捕まった方が
入り込んだ方が安定するって心が思っているんですね
これ勘違いですよ 依存すると自由がなくなるので
別なものに依存対象を変える
そこで我々はいつでも依存を変えて変えていくので
子供はおもちゃに依存する
我々は別なのおもちゃに依存するというね
で 何？依存した方が安定するんだと
だからずっと依存変えて変えていくだけで
こんなのは初めから間違った道なんですけど
わかってない それ ループになって無限に回転するで
限りなく依存する 例えば体が老いていくでしょ
まあ腎臓 腎臓 肝臓などなどが機能できなくなるでしょ
そうすると 誰だって最後に寝たきりになって死ぬ間際になってくると
体に対する依存をなくちゃなくなっちゃうんですね
なくなって心が じゃあ別なものに依存しようと
だから子供はおもちゃに依存して
もうちょっと大きくなっちゃってゲームに依存するでしょ
そんな感じで別なものに依存する
だから死ぬ瞬間で あ 体はもうこれは使えないということで
心が別なものに依存する
この依存症は治らない
で 心は勘違いしています
依存したら安定やと 今もそうでしょう
だから金があったら安定でしょ？仕事あったら安定と思っているでしょ？勉強できたら安定やと思ってるでしょ？依存なんです
よく勉強できたからといって不安がなくなりませんよ
金がいくらあっても不安がなくなりませんよ
新しい不安が生まれるだけ
それでいとも簡単に輪廻転生ということが成り立つんです
心がずっと形変えて形変えて
何かに依存していく これがループになっちゃって
輪廻転生というんですね
えーと 徐々に硬くなる
苦しくなる これはどんどんどんどん心が苦しくなるプロセスですよ
だから人間でいても硬くなって硬くなって自我が強くなっちゃうと堕落していくんですね
輪廻転生するときは だから畜生
餓鬼道 地獄などなどあり
そちらへ行ったりする
そこでまた依存的な心が変わって
また上へ上へ上がったりする
上へ上がっても下へ降下しても
依存症だから意味がないんです
例えば 頑張って徳を積んで良いことをして
死後天国に行く 天国って依存でしょ
そういうことです はい
そういうわけで 我々の心が依存している心なんですね
だから心の現状っていうのは
希望は叶わない 心に能力がない
誰のせいかと あなたのせいでしょうに
広大無限の心でしたのに
この肉体に小さくなっちゃうと能力あるわけないでしょう
悩み苦しみは終わらない
問題が問題がない心はありませんね
心にある根本的な誤解がなくせなくてはいけません
だから依存しちゃったら大丈夫って
その誤解をね なくせなくちゃいかんですね
で 依存しない安定した心になるように育てなくてはいけませんね
育ち方は一応説明しましたから
飛ばします 心は常に学びます
瞬間瞬間 心は変化します
瞬間瞬間の認識 経験などは心を覚えるんです
パーリ語で仏教用語でサンニャーというんですね
常にサンニャーというものは生まれてくるんですね
いわゆるずっと我々は学んでいるんです
それに伴って脳も変わります
だから心が変わると 心は道具として脳を使っていますから
脳も変わります 脳が変わると体も変わります
だから落ち込んでいると心が落ち込むんです
希望叶わなかったとかね
そうすると脳がそれに合わせて変化する
うまくいっていないんだ
そうすると 脳の進行で動く体もうまくいかないんです
この法則は苦から苦へ進むようになっているので
その方向を変えなくてはならないんです
だから我々は苦から苦へ進む方向へ生きているんです
はい これからはこの心の悪い癖変えなくちゃいけない
性格 好き嫌い 物事の評価と判断など
人生のすべては心の癖によって起きます
私の性格って私の心の好きなんです
心の癖なんです 私の好き嫌いは
例えば人間なのに人参嫌いな人がいるでしょ
人間の食い物なのに ピーマン嫌いというかね
そんな タバコというのはあるはずがないでしょ
まあ要するに心なんですよ
怒る 落ち込む 怯える 欲張る
無責任になる 運命に任せる
他人の真似をするなどなどは癖です
人間いろいろでしょ 自分で判断するロボットのように
人を何やってるか見て真似をする
猿の人間もいるんですね
これってその人の心はすごい不安定で
どうすればいいかわからない
じゃああの人の真似すればということ
それで安心ってことでことでしょう
それで安心になるわけないんだけどね
だって落ち込む癖がついちゃうと
落ち込む 落ち込む 例えばすごくごちそうあげたら
なんでご飯にそんな豪華な金使うのかと
落ち込むんです まあじゃあ
じゃあおにぎり２つ なんでおにぎり2つだけ？それまた落ち込む
落ち込む人に何でもいいんです
なぜならば この心にはその癖がついているんです
心が明るい 幸せ 充実感を感じるように経験すると
それを真似る それで逆に心に明るさを経験する
させる 喜びを経験させる
充実感を経験させていくと
心がそれを学んでいくんです
今まで悪いことを学んできたんだけどね
それで心が変わるんです
すぐに幸福を感じる心に変わっていきます
このプログラムは まず弱点を発見することで
不幸をつかさどる弱点を発見してみましょう
まずね それから自分を正当化することをやめましょう
みんな自分を正当化する心が初めから犯人だから
犯人 私は無罪や無罪と言っているでしょ
そんなこと聞いていい？人殺しで捕まって裁判にかけたら
もうこういうこういうことで
何々の人が殺したんだか殺したんだから
あんたはホミサイという
英語で言えばね で こういう罰を受けますよと言ったら
一回有罪ですか？無罪ですと言うでしょ
それで裁判官 あ なるほど
この人は無罪と言うんだから
はい 無罪だったら帰ってください
言う？言わない だから心はいつでも無罪つもりでいるんだけどね
だから自分の自分の正当化することだってしょうでしょう
それやめましょう まず
弱点を自分で発見する
気づかないものを理性のある人から教えてもらって
それも自分で発見するようにします
まず 自分で自分の弱点は何なのかと発見する
発見しないものは理性のある人々は経験ある人
あんたここはちょっと違うでしょと教えてくれる
そうすると え 本当にそうなの？と自分で調べて
それも発見する 第一 自分の弱点を発見する
発見するんです  1 日で人格が改良することをやめて
白黒の判断もしないで
自分の心のありさまを認める
私は怒りっぽいなと発見したら
あ 嫌だ これは怒らない人間になる
やめてくれ そんなのは
それはできません あ なるほど
この心はなんでも逆らって怒るんだと
それに癖があるんだとか
何にも逆らうんだとかね
それでおもしろく見てください
あ この心は自分すぐに嫉妬するんだとかね
嫉妬してすごく落ち込むんだとかね
こんなやつだ この人はと
そういうふうに自分の心を見るんです
見るんです 直さなくてもいいんです
1個だけ変えてみる だからたくさん弱点見つかるでしょ
1個だけ変えてみる 問題を何か一つ選ぶ
それを変えてみる その問題が消えたら終わり
例えば自分が怠け者で怠け者で
いろんなところで失敗しますけど
よくよく見ると じゃあ朝寝坊する
じゃあこれだけやめてみましょうと
仕事をごまかしたり 食べたら皿は洗わないとか
怠けいっぱいあるんですよ
部屋の掃除しないとかね
そういうのは置いておいて
1個だけ じゃあ朝寝坊だけやめてみますと
これが毎回繰り返してみると
なんか自動的に気持ちよくなっちゃってできるようになる
そういう風に心直すんですよ
ですから 素直に変えやすい性格を選ぶんです
かっこつけないで 自分の悪い性格はいろいろとありますから
その中で一番変えやすいもの
改良しやすいものを 1個選んで
そこだけ直してみる すると気持ちよくなります
そうすると じゃあ次に変えやすいことにいってください
性格を変える 努力することがポジティブに見る
それから自分を褒めなくちゃいけない
朝寝坊する人が 一回早く起きましたと
頑張って大変だけど 今日はよくやったよと自分を褒めてください
今日早く起きました とくに
なぜなら そのフィードバックループが必要です
心に 生き方がわずかでも良くなったならば
その成功を脳にインプットするんです
大胆な変化はいりません
1 2 日で大悟大悟りはなくてもいいんです
ほんのちょっと変わったら十分です
次の問題が次に見えてきます
だから 一個だけ選べばいいんです
はい 次のストレッチ訓練というのは道徳に挑戦することなんですね
道徳とは宗教的信仰的なものではなく
正しい生き方なんです
道徳っていうのは 道徳を嫌がってはいけません
我々は正しい生き方をしてないんだ
だから道徳嫌だと言ったっても話にならないでしょう
誰だって正しい生き方はしなくちゃいけない
自分も他人も幸福になる道です
道徳っていうのは 道徳とは道です
ラオツではないんだけど
ラオツ道ということをよく教えてますけどね
これはあるべき姿なんです
我々はあるべき姿を変えて
不自然に生き方をしているんです
例えば 体に酒が必要 いらないでしょう
体の流れ 欲 どう見たってもアルコールでこれは助かってくれたってことは一切ないんです
だから道徳の要点は酒麻薬やめなさいと
これって不自然？それが自然なんです
道徳嫌いは心の本能です
だから心は初めから間違ってますからね
だから正しい生き方は嫌いんですね
だから我々も嘘をつくなよと言ったら
いやだな 嘘をつきたいなという気持ちがあります
殺傷するのはいい 殺したいね
あります 無理をせず 完成できる項目を選んで実行
道徳の場合でも あまりかっこつけて無理をしない
自分に守られる正しい生き方を一つ
二つ 三つ選んで 例えば仏教の五戒っていうのは誰にでも守られるものなんです
そういうものを選んでやればいいんです
幸福になるので 自信がつくので心は成長します
だから心のストレッチというのは
道徳を守れば心がすごく素敵になって柔軟になるんです
すごく拡大していくんです
次 妄想の制御 人間の生き方の指導
時間だそうです えーと
この際で終わりましょうか
思考 思考ですね 思考と妄想が分離できなくなってます
妄想は無意味で無駄な行為
汚れた感情が生み出します
したがって思考も汚れています
間違いです 生きてみると失敗しか起こらない
人生になってない 妄想に主導権をあげているんだから
我々は失敗しか作らないんですね
で この思考 考え 妄想は楽しい
こうやって訓練するんです
この思考 この考え この妄想は楽しい
幸福 気持ちが穏やかになると自分に聞いてみてください
妄想していると 今気持ちとかね
能力は向上する 善または悪
日常生き方の能力が上がる
こういう質問を自分に聞いてみてください
妄想している時のように自分の心に聞いてみる
自分を責めないで見てください
何か嫌な妄想をしていると
今気持ちいい 気持ち悪いねと答えが出てくる
それだけで十分です であるままに見ていると
心は自動的に改良します
なぜならば 次のステップに進むために心は今の瞬間を参照するからです
だから あるがままに見ていくと
心は次のステップを正しくするんです
間もないうちに 幸福に明るく生きられるような脳と心が変わっていくんです
じゃあ  そこら辺でやめましょうか
これは説明しました これは言わなかった
見解の障害 ちょっと読んでみてください
心は瞬時に経験を判断して決定したいという性格です
すぐ判断して だって心には瞬間の命しかないんだからね
判断しないということは
極端に不安を感じる それから判断に固執します
それから変化して流れる世界で生きられなくなっちゃいます
判断したらそこで止まっちゃいますから
生きられなくなります
瞬時に見解が現れます
青い 丸い 硬い おいしいね
きれいなどなど で 変えるのは難しくありません
こんなのは変えるのは難しくないんです
感情 好み 主義 信仰 文化などの影響を受けている見解は明らかに障害になります
だから 何か丸いきれいっていうのは大したことないんです
でも この宗教 感情 好み
その見解ってなかなか変えられませんよ
苦しみになります 心固くなります
これから唯一正しいという邪見に陥る
邪見を捨てる 我々は見解を作ったら
例えば日本文化は世界一唯一正しい
優れていると 見解でしょ
その邪見などなど捨てるんですね
今私はこの意見ですと確認する
データ情報が入り次第
訂正するようにします
次から次へと世間の様々な見解
意見などが変わっていくでしょう
一つの見解に固執することができますかね
できない 私の意見を常に訂正する人間になります
それが心を自由に保つ方法なんですね
それから曖昧もダメなんですね
見解を一切持たないとは
人格完成者のことです
猿真似をすると何もできない
成長しない人間になります
だから私は見解に何も持っていない
何も思っていないという曖昧はダメなんです
心には見解があるんだからね
それを認めてその通りに行動するのも構わない
しかし より良い見解が起きたら
瞬時に訂正しましょう
曖昧はダメ 今の見解で行動してください
でも データが入る次第
すぐ訂正してくださいなんです
ちょっと難しいんでから飛ばしましょう
もう一つ この思考の訓練がありましてね
何かお釈迦様を教えた真理
真理あるんですね この真理を一つ選んで念じてみるんです
そうすると心が治ります
このような真理の中から一つ選んで念じてみる
今 真理リスト書いてましたからね
一つ選んで念じてみると
心の問題が直る方法もあります
納得していくと心は柔軟になります
例えば一切は無常やと無常を念じて生きてみると
すごい柔軟な心になってくるんです
それで完全たる自由になります
最後に心が幸福になりたい
自由になりたいと思っています
常にこの目的を目指して働いています
心が変なことをやっていますけど
間違ったことをやっていますけど
自由になりたい 幸福になりたいという気持ちがあるんです
だから健康になれて毒を飲んでるだけなんです
だから健康なら毒をやめなさいって戒律なんで言ってるのは
しかし 進む方向は間違っています
体を作ったり 輪廻転生したり
感情に負けたり 特には感情を制御したりもします
これがあれば幸せと思って執着の依存に走りますね
我々は で 執着した 依存したものから幸福を感じなかった場合
別なものに執着する 生命の心が流れる方向を 180度変えなくてはならないんです
仏道はその道です 心は成長する
幸福になる 仏道によって
で 智慧が現れてきます
また一枚やります 心は根本的な誤解が解けたところでプログラムは終了です
今 依存は幸福だと思っているが
無執着が真の幸福です
180度変えてみると
日常生活で少々無執着の精神で対応してみましょう
ちょっと日常生活で無執着
ちょっとやってみて すごい幸せになります
成功は驚くはずです 成功にはものに執着するんじゃなくて
ちょっと離してみる すごい驚きます
それでまあ 最後全部読んだことにします
はい それで話は終了です
まあどうですか？もう終わりですか？はい
では この最後の文章を読んで終了しましょう
みんなで合掌して言いましょう
ドゥッカパッターチェニン
ドゥッカバヤッパッターチェニンバヤ
ソーカッパッターチェニッソーカーホントゥ
サッビーピパーニノームジュ
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン
ドゥッカバヤッパッターチェニンバヤ
ソーカッパッターチェニッソーカー
ホントゥ サッビーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみがなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れがなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみがなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
ありがとうございます